je pense qu'il est très important de
distinguer ce qu'on appelle les pme et
puis les grandes entreprises même s'il
ya des nuances aussi entre certaines pme
qui sont gérés parfois de façon
autocratique et quid vendus parfois
qu'ils sont bien gérées et certaine que
compte l'entreprise qui permet de gérer
les terrains mais le loden qui s'est
imposée pour les grandes entreprises
je pense que vous en conviendrez si vous
avez évoqué même c'est le modèle de la
firme d'actionnariat et quand même si en
fait ya des nuances entre les
entreprises du cac 40 mais ce modèle de
la firme actionnariat c'est un modèle
qui s'appuie sur l'idée que la conduire
la finalité de l'entreprise
c'est d'abord et avant tout de produire
des revenus pour les actionnaires sous
forme de dividendes ou ce fort pire au
corps de rachat d'actions 21
l'entreprise utilise une partie de ses
ressources de ses profits pour racheter
ses propres actions les déchirer pour
faire voter le qu on voit bien qu'il
pense a détruit la du capital et donc
ces grandes firmes pour faire toujours
plus de revenus pour les actionnaires
qu'est ce qu'elles ont fait et se sont
enfuis sur le libre échange sur la
possibilité pour elle et c'est bien
entendu les pme ni aux pacsés vous avez
raison là dessus
la possibilité de dire ben tiens pour
produire tel ou tel composant je vais
mettre en concurrence deux ou trois
établissements que j'ai à travers le
monde
il sera clair moitié du commerce mondial
c'est du commerce intra fiam cd commerce
interventions avec les firmes qui fixe à
20 les prix donc avec possibilité de
localiser les activités ici et là
d'attention a fermé deux pics y compris
fiscale et donc sur cette base là les
grandes film pour du dumping fiscal mais
aussi du d'un pic sociales et bien
entendu bête les pme dans un étau
absolument effroyable là puisque pour
faire plus donner plus d'argent ne
comprit pas actionnaire qu'est ce qu'on
fait on dit aubé me faisait bien placé
pour le savoir à quel point les pme sont
souvent écrasées par comment dire par
leur part avril dans leurs dents et je
dirais qu'il faut comme des il faut
sortir de l'idée que l'essentiel de
l'économie
c'est que des pme en france puis savoir
que les grandes entreprises de plus de
5000 salariés jetables que du privé je
prends pas du public bien entendu les
grandes entreprises c'est 30 % de
l'emploi donc c'est quand même c'est si
on prend ce un plus les entreprises de
taille intermédiaire
certes de culte 250 séries on arrive à
la moitié des emplois
[Musique]